When finalizing customizations to the MetaHuman Neutral Pose, DNA calibration can be used
for updating MetaHuman DNA.
In this portion of our course, we delve into setting up the MetaHuman DNA calibration library.
So let's get started with the requirements for using the library and how to set it up.
In this section, we will be setting up the DNA calibration library.
We will also look at the folder contents and become acquainted with some of the scripts.
First, let's review the instructions and requirements for using the repository.
To get started with setting up the DNA calibration repository, sign in to GitHub and then locate
the MetaHuman DNA calibration repository.
Next, download the latest release and then unzip the folder.
Place the DNA calibration folder in a desired location.
In my case, I saved it to my C drive.
Next, go to Edit Environmental Variables and create a new variable named Maya Module Path
in all caps as shown on the slide.
Then set the path location of the DNA calibration folder as the variable value.
Python 3.9 or higher is required for Maya versions 2023 or later,
and the Quixel Bridge Maya plugin needs to be installed.
Now that we have reviewed the setups and requirements, let's go over the folders and
files of the repository.
Inside of the DNA calibration folder, the main files we will be using are located in the Data
folder and Examples folder.
The Data folder contains the files that are needed to load the DNA.
The Body folder is where the prepared skeleton Maya files are placed,
and the DNA files folder is where the DNA files are placed.
Other important files include the GUI and Analog GUI Maya scenes and the additional assembly script.
At the time of the release of MetaHuman Animator in 2023,
the number of joints and expressions increased with the latest version of MetaHuman.
The MH4 folder contains the GUI scene and assembly script for these current rigs.
Update the paths in the scripts you use so that they switch to the new rig version.
The Examples folder contains scripts with common commands.
We will be looking at the DNA viewer run in Maya script,
the grab changes from scene and propagate to DNA script,
and the export FBX script.
The Unreal Fest script is also included in the repository.
And you will find the Assets and Scripts showcased at the Unreal Fest
MetaHuman DNA calibration deep dive presentation.
Now let's review the scripts that we will be using.
The three scripts that we will be using are located in the Examples folder.
The DNA viewer run in Maya script allows you to use a GUI window in Maya
to create a scene with a functional rig.
We can use this to load a DNA file and view the MetaHuman face inside of Maya.
The grab changes from scene and propagate to DNA script
allows you to transfer changes from the Maya scene to the DNA file.
If we want to adjust the head geometry, we can first save the current state,
make our changes, and then save those changes and update the DNA file.
The export FBX script allows you to generate a functional rig in a new Maya scene,
and then export the head LODs as FBX files.
All of the scripts in the Examples folder contain step-by-step instructions at the beginning.
In the Unreal Fest Script folder, you will find that these scripts
include a combination of different functions bundled into one script,
including commands from the Examples folder.
In the next section, we will go through a few simple use case scenarios
for using the DNA calibration library with Autodesk Maya.